there are far deadlier creatures lurking
in the undergrowth
yeah as i discovered when i was out
looking for firewood
this tree right here is a perfect one
see this bark
it's like paper and it just
peels off just like that the bark of
this birch tree
is waterproof and flammable which means
it'll burn
even in the rain
whoa look at that
i did not even see that there
look at the colors on it and look at how
it matches this lichen
so well camouflaged but this beautiful
snake
is also a deadly one
they have infrared sensing pits it's the
kind of sense that humans don't have
but pit vipers do this stealth predator
can detect its prey even in complete
darkness
and it's armed to the teeth look at
those fangs right there
they have hinging venomous
hypodermic needles and those hypodermic
needles those fangs
are hooked up to venom sacks
in the back of its head and that venom
is likely to be some of the most
powerful in the world
i need to be incredibly cautious this
snake is certainly capable
of delivering an extremely venomous bite
one that could even kill me it's kind of
twisting up here
i'm starting to push my luck so i'm
going to release it carefully
and retreat
[Music]
you